[Music]
hi everyone my name is Joey and welcome
to the first of a few guides where I'll
be guiding you through some of the
basics of Dragon Ball fighters now you
might feel at home with the game if you
played a little bit of Marvel vs. Capcom
3 but if you're new to fighting games
the mechanics can be a little bit
overwhelming so what I'm gonna be doing
is breaking them down for you bit by bit
now there's a lot to get through so
let's get started
so we're going to start off with the
basic mechanics that all characters have
and the first one is the Auto combo now
you can debate all you want about
whether or not high level players should
use it but they're actually quite useful
now mashing light attack will get you a
basic combo and there won't be a super
at the end it'll be just a small amount
of damage but it also gives you a random
Dragon Ball and that's mechanic we'll
discuss later and go more in depth in
the future video and now mashing medium
attack will get you a slightly stronger
combo ending with a super now it does
give you more damage but if you want to
save meter or if you're looking to fill
up your Dragon Balls the light attack
will be your go to auto combo next up is
the super dash and if you played any of
the beta you'll likely know what this is
if you have your default controls on
pressing r2 or our trigger will cause
your character to homed in on the
opponent starting a combo if it connects
and it's a fast and easy way to get in
and apply pressure it's safe on block
and can go through some projectiles but
if you rely too heavily on it it can get
countered by a simple anti-air attack or
a super so use it if you know that
they're not gonna react to it or if you
have advantage okay and then we have the
ki blast pressing the special button
will shoot some variation of a
projectile at least with most characters
you know it will differ from fighter to
fighter and you can mash it for extra
hits now these things won't do a ton of
damage and will most likely be eaten by
other stronger projectiles but it can be
good to use on the opponent's wakeup if
you input a quarter circle forward and
then special it will give you a bigger
attack typically some kind of comical ha
or an upgraded version of that
character's projectile now these things
are usually pretty good combo Enders so
for example if you do a light medium
hard air combo you can end it with
quarter circle Ford special and then
maybe go into a super after that and
while we're talking about ki there's
also the ki charge and this is done by
pressing light and special attack and
what you'll do is you'll stand in place
charging up your meter and it gets
faster as it goes up but unfortunately
you can't just
in the opponent's face you'll be pretty
much completely open to attack so use it
wisely or cover it with an assist
and speaking of assists every character
has one and while I'm not going to go
through all of them right now we don't
really have the time I'll just touch on
them briefly now every fighter has their
own unique assist and the trick is using
them in the appropriate moments if you
like rushing people down for example
Vegeta's downward key blastocysts could
be pretty useful or if you like
extending combos you can use kidd booze
or young physicists because those work
wonders
the dragon rush is your Universal throat
and so you'll dash for it a little bit
and then grab them and if you connect
with it it'll launch them up into the
air for a follow-up combo now this is
pretty good for catching people
off-guard or for people who like
turtling a little bit too much it's
pretty quick so try mixing it up with in
your rush contacts so maybe we can do a
block string of light medium hard
special and then maybe follow it up with
the dragon rush but it can be countered
with another dragon rush or another
normal attack and so if you do happen to
land dragon rush what you can also do
instead of combo is that you can follow
it up with a snapback now I'm not sure
what they're called in the game but snap
acts are Marv vs. Capcom term and so
here you what you can do is hold one of
your assistants during the dragon rush
and at the end of the throw it'll kick
out their point character and bring in
one of their remaining fighters you
really want to use this if one of their
reserve characters has a lot of blue
health as it'll get rid of all of it
when they come in so here's another
mechanic that you might be familiar with
if you play marvel and that's the
sparking Black's pressing light medium
hard and special tech all at the same
time will cause you to explode making
your character stronger and allowing you
to recover your blue health
automatically sounds a little bit like
x-factor again in this game it is a
comeback mechanic so it gets more
powerful the smaller your team is so
using it with your last character will
give them a huge boost in damage and
healing if your opponent is pelting you
with projectiles and you've had enough
of it
the Flex can be your friend holding back
and pressing special attack will cause
your character to well deflect anything
that sent their way and that includes
projectiles normal attacks super dashes
and yes even supers you can deflect an
entire super if you time it right and
the timing is only important on the
first hit so for any attacks that have a
follow-up
you know if someone does a bunch of key
blasts you can deflect them all just by
mashing the button
and finally the last one that I'll talk
about is vanish pressing medium and
heart attack will teleport your fighter
behind the opponent kicking them in the
back and also consuming one bar of meter
now you can use this to get out of
harm's way but it's actually more useful
in the middle of a combo as it'll extend
that combo by bouncing them off the wall
now vanish is essentially the gateway to
Dragonball fighters more advanced combos
you know it opens up so many
possibilities and you'll start thinking
about when you want to vanish and what
special moves and assists you want to
combine with it to cook up some nasty
mix ups so those were the basic
mechanics of Dragon Ball fighters I hope
this guide was helpful to all of you
I'll have another guide coming soon that
will go over some of the more advanced
mechanics so look out for that and
remember to visit gamespot.com for even
more dragon ball fighters news Easter
eggs and our review of the game as well
alright guys my name is Joey and thanks
for watching
we're in the shoots
[Music]